all right people all right so I goes
back as requested at it y'all about me I
play this game called Nats of obsession
okay so uh yeah it's a pretty good game
graphic wise i guess and had a player
just check out lined it up toggle it
okay i right crowd okay okay let's see
the prologue real quick okay Oh Harriet
oh hello Harriet was not happy at all
and her husband was out of town for work
she had to pick up michael from hockey
practice she would much rather be at
home taking an easy after a hard day at
work when Michael was ready to leave
Harriet was ready to yell at him for
taking so long all right and as they got
back home here it found a nice surprise
waiting for her husband sent her a
package from his travels he always knew
how to cheer up inside was a beautiful
music box with an intricate Russian
design feeling her eyelids grow heavy
she set aside the music box and decided
to rest for a bit it had been a long day
and she definitely needed some sleep oh
yes okay okay um yeah I got here you go
I'm ready for some notes oh okay really
it is beautiful it is quite beautiful
okay all right where is the music box Oh
beautiful hello hello TV hello all right
let's see if I oh man I'm sexy I should
go in the closet oh hell that's
disgusting um let's say here nice nice
oh good great great we got automatic
closing doors now [ __ ] a that's cute
yeah it's cute right all right I'm gonna
stay here and I'm gonna stay here
[ __ ] locked at those [ __ ] [ __ ]
all [ __ ] wonky and I guess the game
really wants me to go that way yeah
where's this music box [ __ ] uh yeah be
me immediately I on your gang ago hey
huh sir [ __ ] it Swedish ah ok so hey
dash you know swedish english is like
backwards you know like if we just put
mirror to it very nice glitter it's
pretty good usually think [ __ ] is like
way too shiny unreal what is this up in
plastic ok now chairs all [ __ ] up ok
alright so I have you pills yes ok
Crouch crunch crunch ok ok oh I hear I
hear
you have [ __ ] stuck in here all right
little comment I'll comment great great
you know my hand is so white boy that
bench may find that [ __ ] good good this
is good I've always wanted one of these
okay I gotta find out let's sit this
signals it's fine right with the [ __ ] I
thought I trying to interact with the
signals [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] symbol you know oh
what the [ __ ] oh this is [ __ ] great
oh great great this is just great good
give me a TV back oh great this is gonna
be a blast I could tell it's going to be
a blast great great great that looks
like the Watch says here why minutes
what I guess I'd better had this [ __ ] up
better hide over here okay I'll [ __ ] my
[ __ ] bleeding oh [ __ ] this is such
bad timing my ass was bleeding
ok
oh [ __ ] the Elven looking at me hold
ctrl to crouch
what's on the TV my [ __ ] cuz it's
bleeding
okay I can't can I go through this oh no
the current is a rock wall why am I
having to crouch
little Russian dancer please tell me
where to go I'm so scared that I heard
something over here oh yeah there's
there's another one to move forward
Jesus I've actually hid it pretty well
that's a regular English a on the
[ __ ] Alphans [ __ ] yep yet another
one [ __ ] is it yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] now
you watch your music i'll give you the
music
no [ __ ] is it think that's [ __ ]
blowing up
okay a monkey
Kalia oh [ __ ] there's someone these guys
to make the [ __ ] monkey isn't it oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] psycho you know all about this
great back in the closet yeah I can
finally go to bathroom was the blood has
dripped to my leg right what the [ __ ] my
[ __ ] oh my god that's weird get why
not you baby why not yet
Oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
they see a wet sausage
get the [ __ ] out of here over there back
at ok I got it shoots one over there
like I hear the music
oh that's just a machine okay
how I come back okay i'm just doing room
by room now I was sure where that guy is
plan is fine
let's [ __ ] horrifying yeah all right
oh great where's that guy is he like the
kitchen monster
this one okay okay up shiny one oh [ __ ]
my [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] okay
all right
two more
that's weird and I can't run so I don't
know what the [ __ ] that was about
probably go upstairs right
looking looking looking shut lazy like a
mop
okay you got a [ __ ] mop
he's gone he's gone
okay one more one more
okay I think I'm done here let me see if
I have to go back alright I hear the
lobster so I'm going to crash right here
for a second yeah [ __ ] i gave me an up
[ __ ] need to see it's gone on the
everything's open oh yeah baby it is
open and i run sucks you can't run this
game they got with you this is a
critical moment where's the monster
where is a i am white as a toothpick i
am what as a toothpick it's all i gotta
say oh hello sir thank you get him down
Oh itself mutual after no dare not
nothing you the boys like [ __ ] let's
face
okay he's dead though he's that good
good again oh [ __ ] you got to like
stretch mark I was like his neck oh well
okay well it's not very good gang guys I
gotta admit as a good game a lot a lot
of strange things going on and yes I was
obsessed with the notes I was obsessed
oh so thanks for watching and I hope
y'all enjoy it yeah yeah